Elizabeth Smart found alive today around
two o'clock this afternoon in Sandy City
right outside Salt Lake City and we of
course have a team of reporters in the
field right now and trying to get
reaction to this what what we can only
say is an extraordinary and stunning
development in The nine-month
Disappearance of Elizabeth Smart
it was a stunning disappearance a
stunning stunning turn of events Sunday
marks 20 years since Elizabeth Smart was
rescued after she was kidnapped from her
bedroom in Salt Lake City she was just
14 years old at the time and she
survived nine months in captivity she
was found after someone reported seeing
her and police were able to reunite her
with her family and since then she has
worked to help other survivors of abuse
attending events Nationwide and
delivering a message of Hope
2011 she founded the non-profit
Elizabeth Smart foundation and 10 years
later she created a self-defense program
called I liked his name smart defense
and this week she's launching a new
online course called wholehearted con
wholehearted consent it teaches
teenagers how to set boundaries and stop
unwanted advances before they happen
Elizabeth Smart were happy to say joins
us in the studio Elizabeth Smart every
time I see you honestly it makes my
heart saying I remember that day so
vividly when the news broke I I couldn't
believe it I couldn't believe that you
had survived I couldn't believe that you
were alive and it just made me so happy
that you had gotten through this so when
you think of this day approaching do you
is it something you dread is it will it
be just another day for you what does it
mean to you
March 12th is nothing but a good day
nothing but happy day I mean the biggest
Miracle of my life happened on March
12th so it's definitely a good day yeah
and that when when they first found you
you had to say to police and you were
reluctant to even identify yourself
right oh absolutely I mean the prior
previous nine months I had been
threatened and I've been abused and we
had lived in a state of of Terror and
fear and so
speaking out felt like it could possibly
be endangering myself and myself of my
sense of self-preservation I think was
so high was so strong it had kept me
alive for nine months that it was scared
to do anything that that like my my
inner self would view as a risk yeah I
mean you have talked about this publicly
you've written about it but I think
about a girl at 14 who had had no sexual
experience who really didn't know about
sex and yet you were raped for nine
months you're raped every day for nine
months and yet you emerge uh seemingly
very poised seemingly very confident
with a lot of compassion how were you
able to do this how are you able to fall
in love and be intimate with anybody I
mean it didn't happen overnight and had
I come home from being kidnapped and
then like expected to jump into a an
intimate and physically intimate
relationship the day after I I don't
think I could have I mean that would
have been too much but I mean I was
still a kid when I came back so I was
able to go to high school and then I was
able to go to college and I was able to
have these these different experiences
and they really came on uh my own terms
yeah so that by the point that I did
engage in physical intimacy it was it
was my choosing it was with someone that
I trusted with my life and my heart and
and you've said you know the difference
between the two between a loving
relationship and something yeah that's
exactly it I think there's a huge
difference between what uh what loving
intimacy sexual relationship is versus
rape and sexual violence your mom gave
you the best advice what did your mom
say to you
um well first of all my mom's never let
me feel sorry for myself ever whenever
like I was upset as a kid she'd always
say things like what do you do when a
horse bucks you off it I always be like
I hated it I loathed it back then but
I'd be like
to get back on and not I feel like that
really was something she tried to
instill in all of us growing up so the
day after I was rescued she said to me
Elizabeth what this man has done to you
is terrible there aren't word storm to
describe how wicked and evil he is he's
stolen nine months of your life that you
will never get back yeah but the best
punishment you could ever give him is to
be happy yeah don't let him steal
another day and you are happy you have a
husband you have three children and you
said now that this week you're launching
you want to focus on consent for kids
what do you mean by that
what do you want them to know
I want them to understand what consent
is and what it is and I mean I have met
so many survivors who I mean
unfortunately most victims who
experience rape actually know the
perpetrator and and a lot of times it's
with it's with their intimate partner
it's with the person that they choose to
spend their time and their trust with
and it's they don't understand what
consent is I mean if so how would your
program work so it's six modules it's
about 38 videos 38 short videos but it
really makes you figure out what you are
comfortable with it's not me telling you
like this is okay this is not okay I
could never do that yeah
um nor do I have any desire to do that
it's making you really stop try to
understand the concept and then stop and
make you think about what are you okay
with what are your boundaries so that
should you ever find yourself in that
circumstance you know what your
boundaries and you know when that
boundary is being crossed and you can
stand up for yourself because if you
don't know what your boundary is and
something happens I mean
that can have devastating effects I mean
it can follow you and Shadow you for
years to come and that's not fair that's
not right you are giving people a voice
to something that they might not have
thought about and I have to say when I
went to the lobby and I said where's
Elizabeth Smart they said she's sitting
over there I go no Elizabeth is blonde
who is that redhead you changed your
hair you look good you feel good yeah
thank you yes yeah and you travel all by
yourself I go Elizabeth where are your
people you go it's just me it's just
life is good for you people would want
to know your life is great yeah that's
great I mean it's exhausting I've got
more laundry than I know what to do with
yeah it's it's wonderful I wouldn't
change it I so admire you Elizabeth I'm
so sorry you went through that but I'm
so happy that you came out on the other
side and now you really have devoted
your life to helping others that is what
you do Bravo and congratulations it's
always good to see you always you always
always pleasure